wahrscheinlich hast du es aber selber gelesen und jetzt ich muss mal kurz die vorschau richtig
aufmachen und irgendwie backt das gerade ich bin krank ich kann wach sein so weit pepo happy ja
so muss das sein hielt's gut man pepo happy ich hoffe du bist nicht krank weil du pepo
poo poo machen muss also irgendwelchen gründen ich weiß nicht warum ich immer noch diesen kack
avira kram drauf habe auf dem zweiten rechner gut ich weiß weil ich damals installiert habe
verursacht das ding gerade sieben prozent cpu last und ich weiß nicht warum es braucht einfach
wahrscheinlich krypto meiner er activiert war das nicht so dass in avira jetzt den krypto meiner
drin ist tech wait es war nicht bitcoin es war was war es denn es war glaube ich nicht
bitcoin
oder doch weiß nicht macht es jetzt aus ist serien kann sein eine avira in box sagt ganz
wichtig ich musste unbedingt reingucken hast du urlaub habe ich nicht ich arbeite montags
doch nie will come to new avira in box was ist das schon wieder für ein alter kann
mich malen wir uns gerne einfach in die runde ich den zellen dass jetzt steht
ich den
wird es einfach installiert fertig aus remove wird mit dem scheiß avira an install hoffentlich
lässt sich hoffentlich lässt sich an installen darf ein video vorschläge ja kannst du machen
aber wir gucken heute keine videos erst mal schön ins mikrofon gehustet zum glück ist
nicht ansteckend jetzt braucht avira ein komplette cpu kern fürs updaten das wird ja immer beschissener
ich lasse es jetzt laufen also leute passt mal auf heute wird es richtig high
iq wir gucken uns an raid an weil das der chat schon mir seit keine ahnung drei jahren erzählt
max musste unbedingt im android angucken und ich habe es mir auch in der vm schon mal ganz kurz
angeguckt ich habe schon usb stick fertig und ich wollte es heute eigentlich komplett mit
euch machen von anfang an
mache ich im endeffekt auch aber ich habe keinen zweiten usb stick und ich habe angst dass ich meine
trial period resettet wenn ich die gleichen usb stick nochmal formatiere achso wo hast du das her
galileo oder und wie viel ist das in fußballfeldern oder in warzone installationen aber danke für den
sub der eichler leute ich brauche einen gescheiten usb stick ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll sagt
mir mal was ist das für ein usb stick ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll sagt mir mal was ist das für ein usb stick ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll sagt mir
mal was ist das für ein usb stick ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe nur müll ich habe
Problem ist nur, Unraid
möchte unbedingt
einen USB-Stick mit
weltweit Unique
Nummer für den Lizenz-Key.
Das heißt, ich muss
einen USB-Stick nehmen und ich
habe wirklich den allerletzten USB-Stick
irgendwo rausgefischt, den ich gefunden habe.
Einen SanDisk,
Kingston 16G
USB 2.0 habe ich rausgefischt.
USB-Platten
und sowas habe ich mehr als genug da,
aber das reicht ja alleine nicht.
Weißt du, und ich
sollte mir eh mal wieder ein paar USB-Sticks
kaufen.
Einfach ein paar halbwegs gescheite
USB-Sticks, so ein Fünferpack
USB-Sticks, die was taugen irgendwie.
Weil das braucht man immer mal.
Ja, das Ding hier wird
mega heiß, das soll angeblich nichts taugen.
Leute, sagt mir einen guten
USB-Stick.
Wie macht man das mit Lizenz?
Das ist wohl irgendwie an die ID vom USB-Stick
gebunden.
Taugt der?
128?
13 Euro?
Kauft mir das Ding jetzt einfach.
Ja, normalerweise
wie gesagt USB-SATA, aber
gibt's halt gerade nicht.
So, Leute, soll ich euch mal die Hardware zeigen,
auf der wir das ausprobieren? Guck mal.
Ich hab extra für euch
Wir machen heute
nichts in der VM, wir machen das heute wirklich
mit echter Hardware. Ich hab meine alte
Xeon-D-Kiste wieder ausgebuddelt.
Alte Xeon-D-Kiste
ist
, übrigens, nur vom feinsten
Noctua-Lüfter.
Wahrscheinlich waren die Lüfter so teuer wie das Mainboard oder so.
Würdest du Android auf so einem Low-Power-Intel-Board laufen,
wirst du klar, warum nicht?
Ja, dann sagt mir, sagt mir einen anderen
gescheiten USB-Stick. Ich brauch irgendeinen, irgendeinen ordentlichen USB-Stick.
Weißt, was soll ich nehmen? Socken-Leak, was? Stimmt, Socken-Leak.
Tatsächlich. So, und C. Großer C-Leak.
Daumen-Leak.
Eieiei, was hier wieder alles geleakt wird.
Ne, heute waren wir nicht da, okay?
Kreisel-Klein-PVP. Vielleicht, vielleicht heute Abend wieder.
So, also.
Das ist, das ist ne alte Xeon-D-Kiste, die ich hab.
Das ist ein 8, 8-Kern-Xeon-D.
Fragt mich nicht genau, welcher.
Ähm.
Noctua-Lüfter, einfach nur, weil's geht.
Ein SAS-Controller on-board.
Ein Wechselrahmen mit 2x10TB-USB.
Äh, nicht verzeiht.
2x10TB-HDD, was, USB, Schwachsinn.
Ähm.
Ja.
Das Mainboard kostet ungefähr, hat damals ungefähr 1.000 Euro gekostet.
Das war, äh, mit zwei 10G-Anschlüssen und 8-Core, äh, SOC.
Also, da hab ich, äh, tatsächlich diesmal echt Kohle für ausgegeben, und das ist ziemlich
gut.
Aber, maßlos Overkill.
Aber ich hab gedacht, für diesen Versuch buddeln wir das einfach mal wieder aus.
Ist das eine Nextcloud-Alternative?
Nein.
Das ist ein, hauptsächlich ein Storage-System, allerdings mit, ähm, jede Menge Zeug dabei.
Ähm.
Man kann das wahrscheinlich am ehesten mit, äh, so nem Synology zum Selbstinstallieren
vergleichen.
Was der an, was der an Watt zieht?
Es geht.
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Äh, können wir ausprobieren?
Wartet mal, das können wir tatsächlich ausprobieren.
Wo hab ich denn mein, wo ist der Wattchamp?
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich's hingeschmissen hab.
Mist.
Leute, ich weiß nicht, wo ich's hingeschmissen hab.
Ich hatte hier so nen, so nen Messgerät.
Einfach, was man einfach so hinkriegt.
Einfach, was man einfach so inline anschließt.
Aber, ich grabbel mal kurz hier unter den Tisch, ob ich das hier irgendwohin geschmissen
hab.
Ich hab nämlich aufgeräumt und seitdem find ich nix mehr.
Keck, wait.
Ne, hier ist nix.
Hier ist nix.
Mh.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
So, der taugt, oder wie?
Nice, kauf ich mir dann.
Ja.
Wo hab ich denn, wir gucken wirklich mal.
Ich glaub so 30 Watt oder so.
Idle.
Wo hab ich mein Strommess zwischen Stecker hin?
Das kann nicht weit sein.
Ich hab letztens hier erst alles abgebaut.
Wo hab ich den hin?
Ich seh ihn jetzt auch nicht.
Würde mich nämlich selbst mal interessieren, was das, was das zieht.
Irgendwie, irgendwie idle.
Irgendwie 30 Watt idle oder so.
Das ist nicht das Stromsparendste.
Hm.
Oder 20, 25 Watt.
Ich, Moment.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz aufstehen und in der Kiste kramen.
Ich hab da meine fucking PS3 gefunden, aber nicht den Zwischenstecker.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, wo ich den Zwischenstecker hin hab.
Ich find ihn jetzt auf die Stelle nicht.
Ich hab mir extra zwei geholt, weil...
Ah, ich weiß.
Moment.
Okay, Leute.
Keine Ahnung, wo der Zwischenstecker ist.
Ich kann euch also nicht sagen, was das für n Stromverbrauch hat.
Ich hab extra aufgeräumt.
Was heißt aufgeräumt?
Ich hab alles, was ich behalten will, in ne große Kiste geschmissen.
Hab gesagt, hey.
Ähm.
Sortier ich dann später.
Und später ist noch nicht eingetreten, bis jetzt.
So.
Ich bin gerade richtig durchs Zimmer geflitzt.
Okay.
Also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Aus der Pustechamp.
Ja.
Postchamp.
Ne, ne.
So viel ist das nicht.
Das ist relativ sparsam, der Kram.
So.
Darauf installieren wir heute Unraid.
Was heißt installieren?
Wir machen einen USB-Stick rein.
Und dann gucken wir uns das Ganze mal ein bisschen an.
Also.
HM an.
Pustechamp.
Boost Leak.
Ja.
Also ich zeige euch mal kurz, was das für nen Board ist.
Testest du noch Open Media Vault?
Ne.
Open Media Vault mag ich nicht.
TrueNAS könnte man tatsächlich da drauf nochmal ausprobieren.
Ja, das ist.
TrueNAS könnten wir tatsächlich noch ausprobieren.
Open Media Vault hat mir nicht so gefallen.
Es sei denn.
Es sei denn, das hat mittlerweile ne neue Oberfläche und sieht nicht mehr so kalt.
Also, mir ist die Optik ja eigentlich erstmal relativ wurscht.
Ähm.
Aber mir hat's auch von der Bedienbarkeit und der Logik her nicht sonderlich gut gefallen.
Ne
Thirdfield, danke für den Sub
So, erstmal den ganzen
Krempel hier wieder zumachen
Den wir hier noch offen haben
Und bei der Gelegenheit, wir machen gerade mal ein Update
Yes
Arch, Arch by the way
Arch Linux
Man muss das bei, ich hab gehört
Man muss das bei jeder Gelegenheit, wenn das irgendwo
Erwähnt, also wenn das irgendwo angeht
Dann muss man erwähnen, dass man Arch Linux verwendet
Und dann, und dann die Diskussion
Natürlich starten, dass Manjaro kein
Richtiges Arch Linux ist
Was ist Unraid?
So eine Art Synology Kram zum
Selbstinstallieren, das ist anscheinend das
Am ehesten, wie man das
Ich hab's ja selbst noch nicht ausprobiert
Das einzige was ich gemacht hab, ne VM gebootet damit
So
Du hast 30 TB
Speicher, ich hab gerade
20T Platten drin
Weil mir aufgefallen ist, dass da einfach
Noch 12 TB Platten drin stecken
Die stecken, die waren einfach
Die haben einfach noch im Server drin gesteckt
Für nichts
Die waren einfach noch da
So
So, ich werde das Ding mal kurz einschalten
Leute, ich schalte das mal kurz ein
Und dann müssen wir uns gucken
Ob ich es irgendwie noch hinkriege
Mich über das Management Interface von dem Server zu verbinden
So, eingeschaltet ist
Und jetzt gucken wir mal
Was speichert ihr alles?
Ich speichere Gameplay Recordings
Und Backups
Zum größten Teil
So, gleich müssen wir die VM rebooten
Weil Update, Kernel Update erstmal reboot
Schauen wir mal, ob der Server schon ansprechbar ist
Es müsste
Wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe
Müsste das Management Interface
192.168.2
Ach guck mal, wie war das so?
Leute, wir waren da sogar schon mal drauf
Irgendwann
In irgendeinem Stream
Aber anscheinend ist das Management Interface
Noch nicht gebootet
Okay
But why?
Mal pingen
Ping Champ
Zeige ich euch gleich
Ist das irgendeine Firefox Geschichte
Dass das nicht funktioniert?
Gucken wir mal auf dem Chrome
Weil Zertifikat hat das bestimmt kein gültiges
Stopp
Okay, wir warten noch ne Weile, bis es gebootet ist
Ich bin mal eh gespannt
Wie wir da drauf kommen
Das braucht irgendeine uralte Java-Version
Wir haben Xpenology mal drauf
Wir haben Xpenology mal im Stream gemacht
Wirklich?
Kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern
Ist das ein SSL-Error?
Ja, SSL-Error zeigt der Browser auch an
Wenn du HTTPS machst und es antwortet nichts
Das ist auch ein SSL-Error
Wir haben wirklich mal Xpenology drauf installiert?
Ja, das ist ein SSL-Error
Okay
Kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern, aber okay
Dann wisst ihr bestimmt auch noch
Welche Java-Version ich gebraucht habe
Für das Web-Interface, oder?
Wie oft wird Postman eigentlich geupdatet?
Das ist ein stinknormaler
Rest-Client
Braucht der wirklich alle drei Tage Updates?
Ich sag euch
Das ist einfach noch nicht richtig gebootet
Das BMC braucht wahrscheinlich ewig
So, gut
Reboot
Bam
Können wir anfangen?
Gibt es eine andere Java-Version als 8?
Ja
Ich glaube, die sind bei Java 17 oder so
19 mittlerweile
Die haben ja die Benamung umgestellt
Früher war das ja immer 1.6, 1.7 und so
Und jetzt ist es 17
Und die ist zum ersten Mal nicht mehr 1.7
Sondern direkt 17
Ach, was auch immer Oracle da treibt
Das versuche ich gar nicht nachzuvollziehen
So
1 und 2, 1, 6, 8, 2 Punkt
2, 5, 3
Haha
Siehst du, der hat gebootet
Oder auch nicht
Okay, Chrome
Vielleicht geht es im Chrome
Ah, jetzt
Im Chrome funktioniert es, alles klar
Warum auch immer
Nein
Ähm
Wir wollen uns verbinden mit
Oh, scheiße, Mann
Äh
So wie ich mich kenne
Es ist Admin123456
Fuck
Okay, S-Rock
Manual
S-Rock
Ich muss gucken, was es für ein Standard-User ist
S-Rock, Rack
Äh, SFP plus
Mainboards
Wo gibt es denn da eine Übersicht
Das könnte es tatsächlich sein
Das könnte tatsächlich das Mainboard sein
Was ich habe
Zwei SFP plus
Das ist durchaus möglich, dass das das Mainboard ist
So, Manual
IPME Config Guide, User Manual
Ja, okay hier, global, global
Ich muss wissen, was es für ein Passwort ist
Server Workstation
Die S-Rock-Dinger sehen immer so hässlich aus
Die Handbücher
So, Login-Page
Okay
Default User and Password are both Admin
Both Admin
Aber falsch
Forgot Password
Das geht einfach so?
Moment, die haben allen Ernstes eine Reset-Funktion über E-Mail
In nem BMP
Hä?
Was machen die China-Chinesen da wieder?
Okay, lass mal in mich gehen
Was habe ich denn für Passwörter zur damaligen Zeit verwendet?
Das da vielleicht?
Ha?
Ice
Easy
Easy as fuck
Good
Never
Doch, wir safen
Das war das nächste Mal, weiß ich wieder nicht
Okay, also
Was ist das denn für ein Board?
Ah ja, sehr interessant
Product Name nicht vorhanden
Serial Number nicht vorhanden
Part Number nicht vorhanden
Es wurde hergestellt 2012
Ja, super
Wobei, 1. Januar 2012
Das sieht mir eher aus, als stimmt die Batterie nicht
Server Health
Sensor Readings
Gib mir
Okay
Und wie komme ich jetzt auf das Remote Interface drauf vom Server?
Launch
Was?
Was ist das denn?
Failed
But why?
Okay, doch mal mit Firefox probieren
Oh Gott, ich ahne Schlimmes
Doch
Darksteam , das Darksteam hat es kaputt gemacht
Mal reloaden
Prevent Popup, ja ja
Ich allow Popups
Okay
Save
Launch
Wine Browser
Nein
JNLP
J.N.L.P
Oh, No
No
Ist das jetzt den hier im Ernst, ja?
Ha, vielleicht gibt es, ich habe eine Idee, vielleicht gibt es Firmware-Updates für...
Die Sache ist nur die, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es original dieses Board hier ist, aber ich glaube schon.
Erkennt man das vielleicht auf einem Foto, was das für ein Board ist?
Ah, guck mal da!
Was steht da, Leute, was steht da?
Was, was, was steht da?
Chat, Chat.
4, 1, D, J, U.
Zack, wir müssen das drehen.
Self-Image, jawohl.
Wie kann man in Windows Sachen drehen?
Edit Fotos.
Rotate.
Ja.
Zack, was steht da?
20?
20, irgendwas mit 2 O hinten, irgendwas...
2 O, okay, das ist...
2 O 8 R, das wird dieses Board sein.
2 O 8 R.
Ja gut, Leute, ich meine, ich kann einfach den Deckel hoch machen.
Und reingucken, ja, das wird wahrscheinlich die einfachere Variante.
2 O 8 R, korrekt.
Okay, das ist das richtige Board.
Gibt es Firmware-Updates, dass der Java-Shit wegkommt?
BIOS, BMC.
Please read information below before update.
Was haben wir denn überhaupt für eine BIOS-Version?
Februar 2016, ist also einfach mal 6 Jahre alt.
Firmware-Revision 013.
BIOS-Update, BMC-Update brauchen wir.
BIOS-Update ist mir ziemlich wurscht.
Wir müssen ein BMC-Update machen.
Das ist Version 16 und das hier ist Version 13.
Improved, hier, guckt mal.
Improved JViewer Function and Java Compatibility.
Improved Battery Lifetime.
Improved durch den Firmware-Update, nicht schlecht.
Okay, wir machen jetzt mal ein...
Wir machen jetzt...
Wir machen jetzt mal einen BMC-Update.
Das habe ich noch nie gemacht auf dem Ding.
Wie macht man jetzt hier einen BMC-Update?
Firmware-Update?
Ähm...
Ja, ja, Preserve my Configuration.
Das ist nicht verkehrt.
Ey, wie funktioniert das?
Nicht, dass es danach nicht mehr erreichbar ist per...
Gibt es da Infos dazu, wie das geht?
Hier, guckt mal.
How to update.
Was?
How to update BMC Maintenance-Firmware-Update.
Choose File.
Moment, das sieht ganz anders aus bei mir.
Was?
What the fuck?
Wie mache ich hier einen Firmware-Update?
Was ist das?
Wie funktioniert das überhaupt?
Ich glaube, meine Version ist Jahrhunderte älter.
Ja, sieht so aus.
Firmware-Update.
Ich kann meine Firma dann nicht mal hochladen.
Okay.
Der BMC-Update.
Ich brauche jemanden, der mir erklärt, wie ich einen BMC-Update mache.
Ja, ich muss, glaube ich, einen Webserver anschmeißen.
Ich meine, das wäre jetzt auch nicht so das Problem.
Die FDP, der noch schlimmer.
Vielleicht steht das...
Moment, das steht doch hier bestimmt im Handbuch drin.
Guck mal hier, Login-Page.
Update.
Wie macht man ein Update?
Hier, Update.
Update.
Nein.
Remote Control Maintenance.
Firmware-Update.
Also.
Hier habt ihr jetzt endlich mal wieder
einen schönen Stream mit Business Enterprise Server-Hardware.
Und seht ihr, was das für ein...
Was das ist, dass das alles Jahrtausende zurück ist.
Okay, also.
This wizard takes you to...
Reset of...
Enter...
Enter update mode to upgrade the current firmware.
Image transfer.
The page is used to...
Das ist also...
Viel...
Viel hilflos...
Unhilfreicher kann so ein Handbuch nicht sein, oder?
Was steht auf dem Button unten rechts?
Enter update.
Reserve configuration.
The server IP address of the firmware image is stored.
IP address...
Ja, ja, okay.
Full pass firmware...
Das heißt, ich muss einen Webserver starten mit der Firmware.
Okay.
Das...
Okay, jetzt wird es aber langsam echt altertümlich.
Also, machen wir mal neu.
Da.
FW update.
Move das Ding nach FW update.
Unzip.
Das FW update.
IMA.
IMA ist auch ein...
Endung, die ich für Imagefiles noch nie gelesen habe.
Aber die S-Rock-China-Chinesen werden es schon wissen.
So, und jetzt machen wir da einen Webserver auf.
Auf Port...
Port 80.
Ich trau da...
Permission denied.
Okay, 80, 80.
Okay, also.
Haben wir einen Webserver laufen.
Auf...
Ich seh schon.
Das wird ein größerer Arc-Business funktioniert.
Alles klar.
Also, hier auf Port 80, 80 haben wir ein Imagefile liegen.
Okay.
Ich brick das Ding jetzt bestimmt.
Und danach geht gar nichts mehr.
Mach mal Dollar-File auf die Firmware.
Was?
Ach so, du meinst...
Ich soll mir anzeigen lassen, was es ist.
Weil...
Data.
Alles klar.
Binary-Shit ist es.
Server-Address.
Äh.
Leute, ich klick jetzt einfach mal auf Firmware-Update.
Ich klick jetzt einfach mal auf Firmware...
T-FTP mach ich nicht.
Also, was soll da angeblich passieren?
Das ist Scam.
Ich kann da überhaupt nichts eintragen.
Lädt er sich das jetzt aus dem Internet runter oder was?
Okay, Enter Update Mode.
Okay.
Ach, Uploading Firmware.
Mensch, das kommt dann noch.
Das kommt jetzt erst noch.
Ah.
Mein Gott, das ist ja der Versch...
Also, ganz ehrlich.
Ich glaube, das ist der mit Abstand verkackteste...
Das mit Abstand verkackteste, was ich je gesehen hab.
An Updates.
Okay, wo muss ich jetzt hin?
Downloads.
FW-Update.
IMA.
Oder das ZIP.
Was lade ich denn da hoch, Leute?
Das Image oder das ZIP?
Geht das paar Seiten weiter in der Doku?
Weiß nicht.
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht tue ich denen auch Unrecht.
Nee.
Die Doku ist zu Ende an der Stelle.
Da kommt nichts.
Nein, das war's.
Das ist die komplette Doku, die wir uns angeguckt haben.
IMA Upload.
Rasiererwerbung bekommen.
Nice.
Höchstgeschwindigkeit.
Oh, guck mal, es hat funktioniert.
Verifying.
Wahrscheinlich jetzt gleich Failed.
Verified, Failed oder irgendwas.
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Tatsächlich.
Hey, it's been verified.
Von 13 auf 16.
Proceed.
Flashchamp am Start.
Oh, Leute, es dauert ein bisschen.
Schnell Strom ziehen.
Das wäre jetzt, glaube ich, eine ganz schlechte Idee.
Strom abziehen.
Weil, wie ihr seht, das hat ja auch kein Dual-Netzteil oder so.
Ach, geh mal fort hier.
Das hat ja kein Dual-Netzteil.
Das hat so ein ganz normales Desktop-Seasonic-Netzteil drin.
Aber Platinum-Ray.
Rated.
Wo sind die Versionen 14 und 15?
Tja, die gibt es auf der Webseite nicht zum Downloaden.
Es gibt bloß 16.
Huge Highspeed.
Highspeed-Update-Champ hier.
Ich lasse mal das Fenster kurz in Ruhe.
Wo sind wir denn hier gerade stehen geblieben eigentlich?
Hier.
Also.
Download.
BMC.
So, was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Ja, es gibt nur, es gibt nur das.
Es gibt nur von 2017.
Da gibt es eine Firmware-Update.
Und angeblich ist dann die Java-Compatibility improved.
Direkt noch ein BIOS-Update hinterher machen.
Oh, wir wollen es mal nicht übertreiben, oder?
Oh, guck mal.
Improve for Intel Spectre und Meltdown-Bug.
Das sollten wir vielleicht noch installieren, hä?
Okay, noch please.
Device has been reset.
Device has been...
Please close this browser session.
Open new browser session.
This may take about a minute to boot up.
Aber die könnten im Hintergrund ja checken,
ob es wieder da ist.
Aber das war, glaube ich, zu viel verlangt.
Kanal wetten, ob es tut.
Nein, das tut.
Also, wenn ein offizielles Firmware-Upgrade
über den offiziellen Assistent den Server kaputt macht,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Übrigens, lustig, oder?
Wie oldschool dieser ganze Kram immer ist.
Und ich kann euch sagen,
das ist bei aktuellen Dell-Servern zwar besser,
aber du kommst dir auch nicht vor wie im Jahr 2022.
Generell, so Server-Zeug ist immer...
Du kommst dir da immer...
Du kommst dir da immer vor wie 20 Jahre zurück.
Es wird jetzt eh noch gleich lustig.
Gleich muss ich per Java auf das Management...
Also, auf die...
Also, auf das Remote-Desktop-Ding von dem Teil drauf.
Auch nicht funktionieren.
Bei aktuellen geht da nichts.
Aha, aha, ist wieder da.
Nein.
Oh, es geht wieder.
Nee.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Der braucht noch zum Booten.
Der ist nicht so schnell mit Booten.
Ach, da ist er schon wieder, hier.
Excellent.
Login.
Da sind wir wieder.
U-Information.
Immer noch, wir haben immer noch 2012.
Ja, das stimmt.
Die Dell iTracks sind auch HTML5.
Das stimmt.
Also, den Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Kannst du nicht einfach die App vom Server nehmen und...
Meinst du App?
Nicht App.
Meinst du App, die App vom Server nehmen und das per Browser ein...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist im Business-Enterprise-Server-Umfeld gibt es sowas nicht.
Das ist zu benutzerfreundlich.
So.
Kann ich das jetzt aufmachen?
Open Wine Browser.
Nicht wirklich.
Was brauche ich?
Java Webstart hieß das, ne?
Nein.
Arch Wiki JL...
Wie hieß...
Zack.
Wie heißt dieser Kram, den ich da runterlade?
J-N-L-P-File.
Arch Wiki J-N-L-P.
Mit dem Internet Explorer hat das tatsächlich...
Wine über Internet Explorer, Leute.
Ihr seid so fivehead.
Ja, war...
Was Java Iced Tea brauche ich da für?
Java WS.
Open Street Maps.
Nein.
Was Iced Tea?
Das da?
Monka S.
Und jetzt?
Iced Tea Webstart, Leute.
Das funktioniert doch im Leben nicht.
Oh, es ist Java.
Äh.
Digital Signature.
Ersten Error.
Egal.
Trust.
Run.
Wie, das geht jetzt einfach?
Einfach so?
Ich meine, das sieht aus wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend, aber es funktioniert?
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Server Power On.
Yes.
Oh, Leute.
Wisst ihr, ich habe euch nicht schnell genug drangehalten.
Der Lüfter ging gerade ab, wie sonst was.
Der Lüfter hat gerade...
Das ist einen halben Zentimeter hochgeflogen, das Gehäuse.
System Initializing.
Okay, ich darf nicht...
Okay, Leute.
Einmal resizen und nie wieder.
Mehr resize geht nicht.
Bootmenü.
Ah, F11.
Haha.
Bootmenü.
Ich mache mal den USB-Stick dran.
Ach so, wir wollen auch noch ein BIOS-Update machen.
Tatsächlich, stimmt.
Wie macht man ein BIOS-Update?
Okay, next.
Nächste Frage.
BIOS-Update.
BIOS Instant Flash oder von DOS oder Windows aus?
Okay, wir machen Instant Flash.
Global.
Wenn man dafür einen USB-Stick braucht, sind wir gefickt.
Wobei, wir können das einfach hier drüber mounten, das Firmware-Update.
Äh, BIOS.
Nee, das ist G-Bait.
BIOS.
BIOS-Update.
S-Rock Instant Flash.
You can press F6-Key during post or F2-Key to enter BIOS-Setup.
Enter Setup.
Okay, wir machen BIOS-Update.
Auf geht's.
Advanced.
Hm.
Wie könnte ich da jetzt ein BIOS-Update machen?
Jemand eine klarreiche Idee?
Instant Flash.
No image files detected.
Kann man hier BIOS-Update machen?
Nee, oder?
Ich muss das BIOS-Update wahrscheinlich runterladen und dann anhängen über das Remote Management.
Was man kann, ist hier drüber machen.
Wie? Wo?
Maintenance?
Wo denn?
Firmware-Update?
Das ist das BMC, das ist nicht das BIOS.
Maintenance?
Der Chat wieder.
Der Chat erzählt wieder Dinger, wovon er keine Ahnung hat.
Das ist wieder ein typischer Twitch-Chat hier gerade.
Du kannst es aber nicht hier hochladen.
Hier drüber machst du Firmware-Update vom...
Nicht vom BIOS.
Hier drüber machst du Firmware-Update von dem Management-Interface.
So, aber hier geht das.
Instant Flash.
So.
Wo ist das hier?
Instant Flash.
How to Update.
Ach, das hatten wir ja schon.
Nein, das ist für beides.
Chillfreak, du kannst hier nichts hochladen.
Oder meinst du, ich soll das gleiche hier drüber nochmal machen?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das kann es nicht sein.
Save Wi-Fi-Files in your USB-Storage-Device.
Genau das gleiche wie beim BMC.
Okay.
Chat.
Ich...
Mal gucken, ob mir dem Chat trauen kann.
Das testen wir jetzt.
Okay.
Download.
Leute, wollen wir aus China downloaden oder global?
China-Chinesen-Download.
Da sind wir.
Eins hoch.
Aus China direkt.
Das ist wieder was anderes jetzt.
FW-Update.
Ups.
Hat er es jetzt gemacht?
Ja.
Unzip.
Ah.
Die gute alte .30-Datei.
Da weiß man Bescheid.
Okay, Chat.
Ich...
Ich glaube euch jetzt einfach mal.
Enter Update Mode.
Ich...
Ich mache das jetzt mal, was der Chat sagt.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich tippe ja nicht drauf, dass es funktioniert.
Aber...
Ich höre mal auf den Chat.
Ansonsten hätte ich es jetzt über das BMC, also über dieses Remote-Ding eingehängt und über USB geflasht.
Aber...
Ist die 30-Datei dann auch Data?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wie ist Intel Serial Flash for PCH-ROM?
Okay.
Das scheint tatsächlich sowas wie ein BIOS zu sein.
Ah.
Yes.
Obvious.
Hackstump.
Minus C.
Ja.
Klar.
Alles.
Mhm.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Verstanden.
Kein Thema.
Und jetzt...
Und jetzt danach noch eine Runde...
Oh.
Jetzt...
Alle Hack...
Achso.
Update Firmware.
30.
Ich brick jetzt wahrscheinlich meinen Server damit.
Siehste?
Chat.
Chillfreak.
Was erzählst du für Zeug?
Stimmt nicht.
So.
Device has been reset.
Jetzt müssen wir auf ein Reboot warten.
Sehr gut.
Da hört man...
Dann hört man einmal auf den Chat.
Und schon...
Ist das Server halb kaputt.
Vielleicht die Fall...
Natürlich habe ich die falsche Datei runtergeladen.
Ich habe die Datei runtergeladen,
wo mir der Chat...
Der Chat gesagt hat, welche ich runterladen soll.
Obwohl ich schon sofort meine Bedenken geäußert habe,
dass das wahrscheinlich nicht funktioniert.
So.
Jetzt müssen wir warten, bis das Ding wieder gebootet ist.
Pink noch nicht mal.
Chat-Driven-BIOS-Flashing.
Genau.
Oh.
Ihr hört es nicht rauschen, oder?
Ihr habt es nicht rauschen gehört eben, oder?
Ihr habt es nicht rauschen gehört, weil ich raus...
Nein, ich habe Rauschunterdrückung drin.
Ich habe doch hier BigBrainAI-Rauschunterdrückung.
Fällt das?
Rn-Noise.
Rn-Noise erkennt das.
Ich mache mal Rn-Noise kurz aus.
Jetzt müsstet ihr es hören.
Wartet mal, ich halte euch mal dran.
Der geht ganz schön ab gerade.
Der geht ganz schön gut ab.
Fast so wie der PS4.
So, wo ist denn meine Rauschunterdrückung?
Die machen wir wieder rein.
Gut.
Login.
Okay.
Launch.
Open.
Der ist ganz schön am Pusten, der Gude hier.
Ja.
Ach so, Run.
Da sind wir wieder.
Okay, Park.
Also Instant Flash.
Das heißt, wir müssen das mounten irgendwie.
Wie mountet man hier ein Image?
Remote Control.
Hm.
Media.
Virtual Media Wizard.
Browse.
Oh, das sieht alles so modern aus, Leute.
Downloads.
FW-Update.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht immer.
Immer ist falsch.
Wir wollen 30.
Punkt 30 wollen wir haben.
Wobei, das wird ja so nicht funktionieren, oder?
Ne.
Wie kriegen wir die Datei denn jetzt darüber?
Doch, USB-Stick.
Ich mache einen ISO.
Leute, wir machen einen ISO.
Äh, wie geht denn das?
Äh.
Create ISO Linux.
Okay.
Lass uns das jetzt erklären.
Mhm.
Rote Terminal Screen.
MK ISO FS.
Output Temp.
Okay, okay, okay.
MKDir, äh, keine Ahnung.
ISO 0.
MV.
30 nach ISO 0.
Und jetzt machen wir, äh, CD.ISO aus ISO 0.
Okay, wir haben ein ISO am Start.
Nice.
Du brauchst ein FAT32, denn ISO tut nicht einfach so.
Ach, come on.
Ernsthaft, ich probiere das jetzt trotzdem.
Media.
Virtual Media.
FW.
Ich habe keinen USB-Stick, mit dem ich das machen kann.
Ich habe nur einen USB-Stick, und da ist schon Unraid drauf.
FW-Update.
ISO.
Wie, denn ISO kann ich, ich kann nur ein Image machen, kein ISO.
CD-Image.
Wir kriegen schon, wir kriegen, wir kriegen das schon irgendwie hin.
Wir kriegen das irgendwie hin.
Device redirected.
Instant Flash.
No-Image-File.
Nee, nee, das geht nur über USB.
Disconnect.
Hm.
Okay.
Das, jetzt müssen wir kreativ werden.
Jetzt, jetzt müssen wir kreativ werden.
Wie kriegen wir das BIOS-Update?
Äh, create.
Ach, ähm.
Instant Flash, hieß der Kram.
Over BMC.
Ah, der Chat, Chat ist, Chat ist, Chat ist am Start.
Okay.
Leere Datei erstellen.
Loopback mounten.
MKFS FAT.
FAT auf Loopback.
Mounten und Datei reinkopieren.
Da kannst du es in BMC mounten.
Okay.
Also, also quasi sowas wie Touch, Lull, Punkt, Image.
Äh, mount.
Oh, was weiß ich?
Äh, mount, Loopback.
Mount minus O, Loop.
So, genau.
Datei muss eine Größe haben.
Muss ich das zuerst dd'en oder was?
Dd.
EF gleich Def Zero.
OF gleich, äh, Lull Image.
Äh, Block Size gleich 4096.
Und Count gleich, ja, wie groß machen wir das Ganze?
200, so.
Und jetzt ist das Ding 800 Kilo, bei, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen klein.
So.
78 MB sollte reichen.
Okay.
So, und jetzt Mount Lull Image.
Das muss man als Root machen.
Mount Image nach Loop.
Mount Image nach MNT.
Jaja.
Was?
Fail to Setup Loop Device for.
Wie mach ich denn das richtig?
Sudo?
Ne.
M K F S FAT.
Auf, ähm, Lull Image.
Hat funktioniert, okay.
Jetzt konnt ich's auch mounten.
Nice.
Okay.
Und nu müssen wir da drauf dieses Image kopieren.
Das Image oder des Zip.
Leute, was müssen wir, müssen wir da, müssen wir da, ähm, wo ist es denn hin?
Wo ist es denn hin?
Und Zip?
Okay.
CP.
D.
4, 1.
Hä?
D, 4, 1, 30.
Nach MNT.
Vermischen denied.
Ah, muss ich das noch Read, Write, Mounten jetzt?
Das macht man so oft, Leute.
Das macht man so oft.
Muss ich das noch Read, Write, Mounten?
Warum immer Zip?
Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Loop.
Boah, meine Güte.
Okay.
Linux.
X.
Mount.
Image.
RW.
Muss ich da, kann ich einfach so was machen wie RW?
Ah, Moment, ich bin falscher User, ne?
Ja, das funktioniert.
Okay.
Also, CP.
Das da.
Dahin.
Okay.
Da ist es.
Und jetzt?
Einfach anmounten und gut ist.
Kann man das irgendwie so öffnen?
Lull.
Punkt.
Image.
Nee.
Okay.
Wenn der da ist, dann kann ich das auch machen.
Da ist er.
Okay.
Wenn das jetzt funktioniert, dann beiß ich mir in den Arsch.
Also, im übertragenen Sinne, ja?
Okay.
Wir mounten das.
Lull-Image.
Connect.
Oh, oh.
Fuck.
No Image.
Ich muss bestimmt nochmal neu.
Ich muss bestimmt nochmal neu starten, ne?
Ich muss...
Stimmt.
Ich muss, ich muss da ne Partition...
Muss ich da, muss ich den noch partitionieren richtig davor?
Reboote mal.
Äh, gibt's da so nen Reboot-Knopf, dass ich nicht einen ausschalten muss?
Power.
Restart-Server.
Power-Cycle-Server.
Yes.
So, was schreiben die hier nochmal auf ihrer Seite, wie es funktioniert?
War nix.
S.
Rock.
Crack.
Oh, war ich jetzt zu langsam?
Hab ich...
Leute, hab ich vergessen, was zu drücken?
What the fuck?
Geh weg.
War ich zu langsam, was zu drücken?
Ja.
Nee, das kommt jetzt noch, ne?
Hä?
Er liest was vom USB-Stick?
Bootet er jetzt Instant Flash oder was macht der?
Doch, ich hab nen SD-Kartenleser.
Ah, nee, hier.
F2.
F...
Hallo?
Okay.
Wo war das jetzt?
Leute, wo, wo war das jetzt nochmal mit Instant Flash?
Hier.
Aha!
Enter.
Oh.
Was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Was war das jetzt?
Processing Crashless Feature?
Was?
Leute, habt ihr erkannt, was da stand?
Ich glaube der hat mein Enter drücken irgendwie falsch interpretiert.
Processing Crashless Feature.
Was ist ein Crashless Feature?
Crashless.
Das könnte ein neues...
Ohne Scheiße.
Das könnte ein neues Buzzword werden.
wird werden ok wort in slow motion ja das dauert kurz was soll das könnte neues buzzword werden
und seit sind eure programme auch schon crashless ok das war so schnell das kann man nicht mal im
stream durch nicht genug nicht nicht genug nicht genug fps rescan war das okay alles klar irgend
jemand hat es gefolgt auf gefotografiert nice programming success press enter to reboot system
alles klar wird gemacht ach guck mal jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir einen meltdown fix oder so
ich ich das connecte das mal und jetzt sollte er ja eigentlich guten und sagen es gibt kein
betriebssystem da drauf na dann
was genau macht es da guck mal hier sieht schon viel moderner aus jetzt leute guckt euch das mal
mit logo ok jetzt rebootet ja ok der rebootet einfach immer wenn wenn er nichts booten kann
ok da mache ich mal kurz den android usb stick dran jetzt muss ich schnell drücken boot menü war
f11 f11 boot menü
hello entering boot menü nice so server oberflächen müssen immer läge sein
es geht nicht anders kingston kingston dt map partition one da wollen wir booten von
unrate os da sind wir nice pocchampus gibt's das pocchampus
tatsächlich
Es gibt Leute, die schon E-Mails gemacht haben.
Das war ja klar.
Wundert mich nicht.
Gut.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Alter Leute, hier wird es richtig warm im Zimmer
wegen der Kiste hinter mir.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage,
ist jetzt das Betriebssystem
da drauf auch crashless?
Intel 10 Gigabit Network Connection.
Probed.
Alles klar. Nice.
Er hat probed.
Mit dem Crashless Patch
sind alle crashless. So mag ich das.
Er ist ganz schön langsam
beim Starten.
Login. Okay.
2.128
Ach ne.
Ich dachte schon.
Aber wir wurden gar nicht gebatet.
Das heißt, ich kann es jetzt ausmachen.
Nice. Okay.
Sehr schön.
Also.
Was haben wir hier zu bieten?
VMware is missing. Ja, das ist okay.
Also, ich habe drinnen
in der Kiste
10 Terabyte
2x 10 Terabyte
und
2x 64G SSDs.
Airflow.
Failing now.
Was?
Äh.
Wird es zu warm oder was?
Hä?
Ich meine, 24 Grad erscheint mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt
absolut in Ordnung.
Jetzt dreht er wieder voll hoch.
25 Grad. Eindeutig zu heiß.
Ja. Dashboard.
Was gibt es sonst noch?
Guck mal hier. 8 CPUs.
Ne, 16 Kerne
mit Hyper-Threading.
Aber in Wirklichkeit sind das nur 8 CPU-Kerne.
Also, für 2016
war das Ding richtig pock.
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen mit der Temperatur?
Error.
Ach, deswegen hier.
Airflow Temperature
von Dev3.
Hä?
Ich glaube, das ist
gebetet.
Und was sagt mir
das jetzt?
Disk Temperature 75 Grad.
Ja, wunderbar.
Aber die Disk Temperature ist ja
...
ist ja 25 Grad.
Okay, also, was macht man
da jetzt? Wie gesagt, ich habe
einmal das in der VM gestartet. Das war's.
So. Also, was kann ich denn
jetzt hier machen? Ich habe da ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keinen Plan.
Also, Parity Disks.
Also, kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel sagen,
die Platte und die Platte
ist das jetzt
so eine Art RAID 1 oder sowas?
Oder ist das, oder
ist das, ähm,
20T?
Ne.
Was ist das jetzt?
So muss ich das wahrscheinlich machen, oder?
Wrong.
Was hast du für Schmerzen? Airflow Temperature?
Du musst erst mal
ein Array erstellen. Ja, das mache ich doch hier, oder?
Oder kommt
er damit nicht klar, weil ich da schon mal
eine VM-Disk dran hatte?
Es ist gar kein RAID, deswegen heißt
es UnRAID. Ja.
Five Head Time.
Missing, Disabled, Contents.
Alter, was willst du mit meiner Airflow Temperature?
Airflow Temperature
ist
26. 26 Grad.
Das ist viel zu warm. Ja, sehe ich auch so.
However, disk is missing.
Wie kriege ich denn das abgewöhnt,
dass er das ignorieren soll?
Gar nicht, ja?
4 Disks.
Delete Array.
Aber wenn ich hier sage, das da,
dann mag er nicht.
Parity.
Was? Tools?
Tools und dann was? New Config?
Was ist das?
This is a tool to reset
the array disk configuration that
all disks appear as new, as if a
fresh server.
Okay, yes.
Okay, done.
Ah.
Alter,
okay, was
der mir sagen möchte mit
meiner Airflow Temperature ist mir
unbegreiflich, aber okay.
Okay, wir haben eine Diskplatte, eine
Parity-Platte. Das ist dann quasi
sowas wie RAID 1 wahrscheinlich
zu dem Zeitpunkt noch.
Rate ich jetzt einfach mal.
So.
Guck mal, ich hab aber noch 2
64G SSDs.
Kann ich die irgendwie als Cache nehmen?
Kann ich die irgendwie als
Cache nehmen, dass sie schneller wird?
Die SSDs?
Vielleicht wenn ich hier auf
mehr hochgehe, dass es da irgendwie
die Auswahl für Caches gibt?
Ne.
Add Pool.
Cache.
Slots 2.
Add.
Ah.
Okay, jetzt hab ich 2 64...
Die SSDs sind übrigens nicht sonderlich schnell.
Das sind alte Server-SSDs.
Also sprich...
Also jetzt hab ich 10TB,
RAID 1 und
ein Cache Pool.
So, das ist mein USB-Stick.
Das bringt nix.
Okay. Start.
Proceed.
Also die Warnung gehen wir echt auf den
Sack, wenn der meint das 26k...
Was jetzt? Okay.
Hä?
Unsupported Partition Layout.
Okay.
Muss ich das jetzt formatieren?
Yes.
Ich formatiere. Ich meine, da ist eh nix drauf,
was ich bräuchte.
Start Formatting. Dann gib ihm mal.
Ja, die Airflow Temperature
ist schon krass.
Hat das Ding die Möglichkeit, dass man
die Lüfter kontrolliert?
Also hat das ein Plugin
für...
Oh, wie hieß diese...
Fan...
Ne, Sensors?
Hat das was für Sensors?
Dass ich die Lüfter, dass ich die Lüfter
regeln kann?
Weil der Solver geht mir grad voll auf den Sack.
Oder ich muss den BIOS nochmal rumstellen.
Ja, ALM Sensors, genau.
Okay.
Ist der jetzt fertig?
Warum macht der denn BTRFS
auf den Cache?
Hat das irgendeinen Sinn?
Und warum ist die...
Hälfte used?
Warum ist die Hälfte von meinem Cache
jetzt used?
Ich hab doch noch gar nix gemacht.
Hier steht, was der Airflow ist. Okay.
Zeig her.
Clever.
Fehler.
Ist das ein Risiko?
Was ist denn das für eine Seite? Das ist doch irgendein Stack Overflow.
Crawler.
In der Vergangen haben ihre Laufwerke
Lufttemperatur von 362 Grad gemessen.
Die Antriebe melden aktuell...
Ja, und weiter?
Jetzt ist doch alles in Ordnung.
Installier mal Community
Applications.
Warum soll ich irgendwelche Community Applications
installieren?
Ich guck mir das jetzt erstmal an.
Mit dem SSD Cache wird Monero für
Unraid gemeint. Ja, ja, ganz bestimmt.
Also wenn die das wirklich machen,
ist es das erste, was ich rausschmeiße.
Was ich mir aber nicht vorstellen kann.
Die wollen ja Geld dafür.
Gut. War's das jetzt?
Das war's, oder? Mehr muss ich nicht
machen.
Jetzt hab ich einen Cache.
Der macht jetzt einen Parity Rebuild.
Wie seht ihr das doch? Fertig angeblich.
Angeblich ist er doch durch.
Was macht der denn da?
Used.
Free.
Ohne die Community
Applications ist Unraid useless.
Ja, ich will mir das trotzdem erstmal so angucken.
Siehe unten.
Wow.
Was zum...
Aber man kann das trotzdem verwenden, oder?
Was macht der da überhaupt?
Ich mein, die Platten sind leer.
Kannst du canceln?
Okay, canceln. Wie cancelt man das?
Cancel.
Cancel. Bam. Weg damit.
Alles gut. Passt.
So. Okay, wir machen...
Jetzt muss ich erstmal die Geschwindigkeit testen.
Guck mal erstmal wie schnell.
Am Server selbst sollte das nicht liegen.
Wir haben einen ordentlichen Cache.
Wir haben zwei 10 TB Platten drinne.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich hab ne 10 GB Adapter hier bei mir drinne.
Also, schauen wir mal.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Wie legt man denn den Windows Share an?
Share. Users.
So, wo sehe ich denn überhaupt meine Platten jetzt?
Shares.
Appdata? Systemdata?
Ah, hier ist ja nix drauf.
Okay, Shares.
Der macht keinen Raid. Ja, aber ich hab doch nen Cache.
Ich hab doch nen Cache.
Deswegen sollte das schneller gehen.
Okay.
Adshare.
Äh.
0w.
Comments. Brauch ma net.
Use Cache Pool. Yes.
Select Cache Pool. Cache.
Enable Copy on Right.
Ich lass einfach Steine.
High Watermark.
Was auch immer.
Ich lass einfach alles.
So wie es ist, oder?
Adshare.
Und welches Verzeichnis?
Und welches Verzeichnis nimmt der jetzt für den Share?
Einfach komplette Disk, oder wie?
Ähm. Share Name.
Okay, das bedeutet,
wenn ich jetzt in mein Windows gehe.
Was? Nein.
Kein Sega, was ich mir jetzt angucken will.
Ne, warte mal. Wo muss ich denn jetzt hin?
Explore.
Explorer muss ich aufmachen.
Haha, der Chat wieder.
Oh. Aha. 0w.
Da sind wir.
Okay. Äh. 0w.
So, wie testen wir jetzt mal, wie schnell das ist?
Wir kopieren
ein Image rüber.
ein Image.
Und zwar.
E. Unraid VHD.
Das ist, das ist meine.
Das ist die, ähm.
Test-VM, die ich erstellt habe. Genau.
VMs.
Jubantu 21 kopieren wir.
25G.
Und zwar kopieren.
Copy.
Moment. Habe ich über, gehe ich überhaupt über Gigabit?
Sekunde. Ähm.
Moment.
Ich muss mal kurz hinten an meinen Rechner gucken.
Nicht, dass ich, nicht, dass ich nur über
Gigabit dran bin.
Warum bin ich nur über Gigabit?
Warum habe ich das?
Ich bin nur über Gigabit.
Warum habe ich denn das hinten an meinem Rechner umgestellt?
Wo sieht man das in Windows
denn jetzt gescheit?
Transfer? Intel?
Äh, okay.
Warum bin ich nicht
über 10G?
Moment, Leute.
Ich bin gerade verwirrt. Warum bin ich nicht
auf 10G?
Ich habe mich doch mal über 10G
angestöpselt.
Weil? Warum? Warum?
Gab es damit vielleicht
Probleme?
Gute Frage. Ich hätte wetten können, ich bin
über 10G angestöpselt.
Hm. Warum bin ich über 10G?
Das Problem ist,
ich kann das jetzt nicht umstöpseln.
Wenn ich das jetzt umstöpsel, geht das Stream aus.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz gucken. Vielleicht kann ich es
zusätzlich noch anstöpseln.
Wartet mal.
Weil ich weiß genau, ich habe,
wir haben das ja hier mal zusammen,
wir haben das ja hier zusammen mal getestet.
10G, das weiß ich noch.
Da hatte ich mich auch per 10G angestöpselt.
Wartet mal, ich muss mal kurz, weil es kann sein,
dass zwei das Netzwerk haben.
Genau, zwei das Netzwerk haben.
So, ich habe jetzt ein schön langes
10 Meter Kabel geholt.
Und das stöpsel ich jetzt mal dran und dann hinten
an meinen Switch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das
weggemacht habe.
Hm. Sehr merkwürdig.
Okay, na gut.
Ich stöpsel es mal kurz hinten an meinen Rechner dran.
Leute, ich bin mega verwirrt. Das Kabel passt
nicht mehr in den Netzwerkanschluss.
Wie geht denn sowas?
Wartet mal, das muss ich mal kurz machen.
Ich muss mal kurz Licht, ich muss mal kurz Licht
holen und hinten an den Rechner leuchten.
Moment.
Da ist,
ich muss montags nie arbeiten.
Da ist
von diesem Abdeckungsding vom Mainboard
ist eines dieser
Festhalteclips in den
Port gerutscht.
Jetzt müsste es funktionieren.
Ich stöpsel es jetzt mal an meinen Router dran.
Oder besser gesagt an meinen 10G Switch.
So, hat sich was getan?
Habt ihr irgendwas gesehen, wo ich es eingestöpselt habe?
Aha.
Connected.
Warum ist dieses Windows-Netzwerk-Settings-Ding
so abartig beschissen gemacht?
Wo sehe ich denn jetzt, wie viel...
Hier.
Gesynct Gigabit.
Gesynct...
Gigabit.
Hä?
Das war doch vorher auch schon connected, oder?
War das vorher nicht connected?
Not connected.
Den brauche ich.
Okay, Sekunde, Leute.
Ich habe mich jetzt ans Falsche gestöpselt.
No Internet, okay.
Connect.
Mit...
Warum?
Alter.
Okay.
Jetzt müsst ihr das nochmal checken.
Connected.
Identifying.
Könnt ihr mir mal erklären, warum das so beschissen gemacht ist
in Windows?
10G. Ja. Ja, wunderbar.
Wir sind mit
10G connected. Alles klar.
Wunderbar.
Excellent, excellent.
So, wie erkläre ich dem jetzt,
dass der gefälligst diese Verbindung nehmen soll
für die...
für das zum Kopieren?
Ja, so schlau ist er nämlich nicht.
Wie sage ich dem jetzt, dass der jetzt über diesen
Brio ändern im Adapter?
Ja, aber dann geht
mein Stream kaputt, oder?
Kann ich nicht
einen Routing-Eintrag machen?
Anderes Kabel ziehen, dann ist
das Stream aus.
Ich kann das Stream nicht reconnecten.
Leute, wir probieren das. Ich ziehe das Kabel jetzt.
Wir testen es jetzt. Ich ziehe jetzt mein Kabel.
Achtung.
Schauen wir mal.